Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde
gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke schön.
Herr Heinrich Tietmann ist 53 Jahre alt, 1,80 Meter groß und 60 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Tietmann stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seiner stundenbestehenden, krampfartigen, persistierenden
Atakformiga Oberbauchschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen würden in den Rücken aus und dem Patienten zufolge sein.
Die Schmerzen nach dem...
Herr Haydar, können Sie die Säule über die Erspernung noch einmal sagen?
Welche Säule?
Die Schmerzen würden in den Rücken aus und dem Patienten zufolge sein.
Okay, okay, ja, Sie haben recht, genau.
Okay, den Patienten zufolge sein.
Herr Haydar ist abgelaufen.
Er ist gekommen.
Ich glaube die Internet wird kaputt.
Hört ihr mich?
Wir hören dich.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen nach dem Frühstück aufgetreten.
Der Patient habe Fett geessen, wie zum Beispiel Butter, Brot zum Frühstück gegessen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzskala mit 9 von 10 bewertet und der Patient habe dagegen kein Medikament eingenommen.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass die Attacken ca. 15 Minuten andauern.
Er berichtete über Nausea und die Fragen nach Emesis, Icterus, Pancina, Pectoris, Herz, Tachikadi, Dyspnoe und Ptosis wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Inapetenz und chronische Obstipation seit langem und der Patient nehme dagegen Movi-Col zweimal pro Woche ein.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte der Patient seit 12 Jahren bestehende arteriale Hypertonie, seit 5 Jahren bestehende Hyperkolestrinämie und seit 8 Jahren bestehende Discosprolaps im Lendenbereich.
Er nehme Kandesartan 8 mg morgens, die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden und final...
Der Patient benutze gegen Discosprolaps Finagonsalbe bei Bedarf 3x pro Woche.
Als der Patient Kind war, sei er wegen herrnia umlicalis operiert worden.
Er sei wegen herrnia umlicalis operiert worden.
Vor 10 Jahren sei er wegen Arthrose am Fuß operiert worden.
Er habe Kreuzallergie gegen Äpfel und Birken, die sich durch Pruritus, Exanthem, Abdominalgie und Rhinokonjunktivitis äußern.
Er habe Fructoseintoleranz, die sich durch Meteorismus und Verdauungsbeschwerden äußern.
Er sei Raucher und seit 17 Lebensjahr, 15 Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinke 2-3 Flaschen Wein pro Woche und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 76 Jahren an Pancreas Casinom verschoben sei und die Mutter leider an Herzinsuffizienz.
Er sei Einzelkind, verheiratet und habe 3 gesunde Kinder.
Er wohne mit seiner Frau und sei Bürokaufmann von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf akute Pancreatitis aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Oberbauchschmerzen, die Schmerzen würden in den Rücken ausstrahlen.
Er trinke 2-3 Flaschen Wein pro Woche.
Das ist ein Risikofaktor für eine akute Pancreatitis.
Die Alcyphalansia Diagnosen kommen mit Myokardinfarkt, Unkuss, Ventriculis, Scholelytiasis in Betracht.
Zunächst würde ich beiden Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, Schwellungen am Bauch vorhanden sind.
Ich achte darauf, ob der Patient Druckschmerzen und Abwehrspannung hat.
Zusätzlich würde ich eine Labouruntersuchung durchführen, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Glückbild, Lokotytensal, SGAP, Amylase, Lipase, Herzensime, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyden und Gerinnungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Röntgenuntersuchung veranlassen, um die Perforation auszuschließen.
Welche Röntgenuntersuchung?
Röntgen des Abdoments durchführen, um die Perforation auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich eine Abdommensuntersuchung veranlassen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT-Abdommensuntersuchung durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Und ich würde auch eine LKG- und Echokardiographie durchführen, um die Herzkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten im zerminierten Zugang legen.
Dann würde ich Flüssigkeit zuvor, Analgetikum, Antiemeticum verabreichen.
Und ich würde ein chirurgisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortsetzen.
Ich verstehe Sie. Sie haben gesagt, ich werde den Patienten im zerminierten Zugang legen. Was verabreichen Sie den Patienten?
Ich würde als symptomatische Therapie Analgetikum, Antiemeticum und Flüssigkeit zuvor verabreichen.
Wie viel Flüssigkeit zuvor geben Sie den Patienten?
Ja, gute Frage.
Ich habe anders formuliert.
Haben Sie eine Vermutung? Der Patient hat einen hypovolemischen Schock.
Während der Pancreatitis gibt es mögliche hypovolemische Schock.
Und geben wir den Patienten mit Flüssigkeit, Antibiotikum, auch sehr gefährliche Situation.
Was denken Sie?
Ich würde die Ursache von dieser Situation beurteilen.
Wenn der Patient einen Stein im Kolledok hat, können wir diesen Stein entfernen.
Das ist eine Kontraindikation. Ich würde RACP sagen, aber das ist eine akute Pancreatitis.
Nein, ich glaube keine Operation. Ich werde nur den Patienten beobachten.
Wenn es eine Perforation gibt, würde ich den Patienten operieren.
Oder eine Pseudokistin im Pancreatis hat.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, ich würde den Patienten eine Abdomenzonographie durchführen. Können Sie uns diese aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Herr Oberarzt, ich werde Sie über die Abdomenzonographie aufklären.
Ich würde Sie über die Abdomenzonographie aufklären.
Die Abdomenzonographie ist eine Untersuchung.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Tumore und andere Veränderungen des Abdomens zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung ist sowohl schmerzfrei als auch strahlenfrei.
Wir sollen vorher ihren Bauch mit einem Gel einschmieren, damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Die Ultraschallwellen machen die innere Organe sichtbar.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten.
Dafür benötigen Sie keine besondere Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen. Sie können Ihren Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Sie können oder der Patient kann?
Der Patient kann seinen Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Hat diese Untersuchung eine Alternativmethode?
Wir können also eine CT des Abdomens oder MRT des Abdomens durchführen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass wir während der Untersuchung die Ultraschallwellen nutzen und den Patienten in der Organe sichtbar machen.
Wie können wir das sichtbar machen?
Die Ultraschallwellen gehen zu den inneren Organen und zurückkommen auf einen Monitor.
Ich möchte diesen Monitor oder ein besonderes Gerät auf einem Monitor aufbauen. Damit können wir die inneren Organe aufbauen.
Herr Kollegen, bitte gehen Sie auf unser Infodisk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat. Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg in Ihrem Arbeitsweg.
Danke, dass Sie nett von Ihnen, Herr Oberarzt.